the backdrop for the oscars has never
been so cinematic
los angeles union station has been the
site of hundreds of movies and now
for the first time ever this sunday it
will be the home to the oscars telecast
so here's the big question how are they
going to pull it off it truly is one of
the great
mysteries in hollywood and we're here to
help you unravel it
[Music]
we're back we are commencing the
backness
it's a welcome distraction i think it is
healthy for us to get back to some sense
of
normalcy new normal
old normal i've never been invited ever
so
whatever it is to me i'mma be like this
is
great brad pitt halle berry rhys
witherspoon renee zellweger and zendaya
are among the presenters who will be on
hand for sunday's live
in person show now the big event will
take place primarily from here at la's
historic union station
oscar crews have been working around the
clock building stages
lounges and interview spots it's my test
ben affleck's pearl harbor charlie's
angels full throttle
and dark knight rises have all been
filmed here
let's talk about the oscars and why
union station we needed a space that we
can have to ourselves and create
an environment that we can safely be
able to execute the show
the most important thing for the oscars
to do is to make sure that it's a safe
event
sunday safety protocols include three
covid tests
a temperature check and an audience
capped at 170. so what do you do for
that night because they are limiting it
i'm taking my agent who is also my
manager she's one person
she's also my best friend and i've been
with her since i was 16. i like that
how will you accommodate everybody so
they can be unmasked
the answer is that literally you listen
to experts
and you know you take the right advice
from the right people
the dress code formal it has to be
fabulous what can you tell me about the
red carpet aspect of the night
you know what it's all different it's
all blown up and changed but
hopefully in a really good way all right
we were told the first 60 seconds are
going to be
incredible your knees are going to
buckle you know you know what
you just have to watch and call me
afterwards and tell me what you think
we're told this won't be a typical award
show instead it will feel more like a
film
as for the musical numbers speak now
[Music]
they'll be shot across town here on the
rooftop of the academy museum of motion
pictures
nominees include leslie odom jr and her
the fact that i can still do what i love
and give people hope through music and
it feels crazy and i'm excited
as for the oscar parties
duolipo will join sir elton john for his
annual
bash with husband david furnish elton
changed out of a robe and curlers
sending out
this invite for the first
to our time elton john aids foundation
oscar party
tickets to the virtual event are 19.99
[Music]
little interesting tidbit for you you
know la union station hosts about 110
000 commuters each and every day and
folks have been coming in and out
while we're here today and it won't be
closed during the award ceremony either
so
you can catch a train while like brad
pitt is over there partying